in El Salvador 2 000 prisoners are
herded into a Maximum Security Prison
its disturbing footage
they've been jailed without Fair trials
as part of a nationwide Crackdown
and what's really shocking about this
video is it was posted by the country's
president
has locked up tens of thousands of young
men yet across Latin America he's more
popular than the Pope
I traveled to El Salvador to find out
why this increasingly authoritarian
leader has approval ratings of 80 to 90
percent president bukele offers A
playbook for how to dismantle a
democracy while remaining popular
[Music]
the standing on a road outside of prison
in El Salvador
tens of thousands of young men rounded
up by the police accused of being
gangsters and locked up without anything
remotely resembling a trial along this
road mothers of them wait for a
possibility of a glimpse of their son
I've been transported out of the prison
or sometimes tragically taken to
hospital after beatings inside
these families are feeling the effects
of one of the most intense Wars on gangs
Latin America has ever seen
El Salvador has long been plagued by
stratospheric levels of gang violence
like nearly every president of El
Salvador naiba Kelly won office on a
promise to crack down on gangs unlike
previous presidents he did so with a
ferocity that was quite unprecedented
head program was to toss out the old
rule book and round up a huge proportion
of the young male population of El
Salvador
anyone whom the police remotely
suspected of even distant ties to a gang
on the flimsiest of evidence could be a
dodgy tattoo could be an anonymous
tip-off
so far mukelee has locked up the
equivalent of seven percent of El
Salvador's young male population
on the streets near San Salvador people
seem unfazed by bukele's tactics
foreign
neighborhoods it used to be that
gangsters could Swagger into people's
shops and demand money and the
shopkeepers would feel they had to pay
up because if they didn't they'd be
killed and they didn't think that anyone
would do anything about the gangsters
because that would require testimony
which everyone was too scared to give
now that's changed the gangsters know
that just one phone call from an
anonymous person can get them locked up
indefinitely
many salvadorians are delighted that the
gangs have lost their grip but the
families I saw outside the jail told a
different story
foreign
with over 70 000 people imprisoned on at
best circumstantial evidence it didn't
surprise me that the women I spoke to
wouldn't risk showing their faces
they didn't want to appear on camera
because anyone can be locked up on no
evidence in El Salvador so they're
terrified
this is Gustavo viatoro El Salvador's
Minister for justice and internal
security I challenged him on his
government's erosion of due process
will the
group who are being held
their trials how long will it take to
finish their trials
where this is
we are working the the trial against
them already started 63
000 of them are under a judge decision
in prison
but we expect maybe
24 months more to
finish the trial against
and these trials are the individual
trials or group trials in group and what
do you say to the human rights groups
who say that this Crackdown has been
pursued without proper regard to Human
Rights we don't work for
human right organization
we work for Salvadorian citizens
it's not just due process that pokelay's
government is chipping away at he's
dismantling other checks and balances
largely in the name of keeping
salvadorians safe
so he purges the Judiciary of Judges who
want to restrain him he is reducing the
size of Parliament and gerrymandering it
to increase his party's control he's
even using crime as an excuse to gag the
media by passing a terrifying law which
imposes jail sentences of 10 to 15 years
for any report that causes anxiety or
amplifiers supposedly any messages from
gangs
[Music]
for now most salvadorians are
celebrating the peace that's come back
to their streets but over time they may
discover that they've traded fear of
gangs for fear of a police state
and Robert guest the deputy editor of
The Economist to read more of our
coverage of Latin America and indeed
what's happening in El Salvador please
click on the link and don't forget to
subscribe